since the beginning of time man has had
a fascination with his own extinction
but what exactly will be the catalyst
the question of how our demise will come
has intrigued and plagued us for as long
as we can remember will it be by zombie
what are you doing
oh haha let's dress up like a zombie and
scary antics we know she's afraid of the
walking dead maybe some evolved ever
mutating book our religious coming don't
lie every one of us secretly hopes that
if were the generation that witnesses
the end of the world that we'd have the
balls to survive it I mean it's kind of
like like I've never been in a fight but
I've always wanted to just to prove that
I could win don't get me wrong I don't
have a death wish or anything but the
fucking post apocalyptic genre is so
cool like why the last man the Stan
Logan's Run I am Legend oh my god what
is it about the threat to our existence
that turns us on
so much I'm getting a boner so tell me
friend how do you think humanity will
end mind that doesn't kill the entire
human race stay awesome Gotham I'm
running a fever
and I'm all like medicated I normally
don't take meds but Ray was like take
maths cuz you've been sick like three
days but it's not gonna go away unless
you take meds and so the meds couldn't
battle the sickness this is spot on oh
this is Anna's antibodies this tylenol
in liquid form is so girls but after
like 15 minutes yeah I again I wish I
was like all that song
forgive me forgive me eggs no sense
beaver into the state of mind you're
sick